let me ask you though
about racism
do you as you travel through this world
as you travel through america
feel the burn
of hatred
um you've spoken about the revolutions
that have been fought throughout the
20th century
against racism
but today as people talk about educating
reminding the world with the
even with more philosophical ideas of
critical race theory for example
do you think this is still
a battle that that
needs to be fought at the forefront of
culture in the united states
um
does racism exist
yes it does
but all forms of isms exist
some people it's about various forms of
ableism
others it's about size
um and racism yes is one of them
does it exist yes it does
but
is it what's going to stop anyone from
manifesting their greatest potential
i say no
i say no
many people in this country have showed
it
whether they're african americans or
african african immigrant i'm an african
immigrant
you have african-americans like oprah
and others and other people even before
her
who
despite the nastiness around them were
able to make it
so we do know
especially as black people but i think
it's humanity as a whole
and that's what i love about the human
spirit it's resiliency
but resiliency only can happen if you
don't allow yourself to be beaten down
and to lose your self of agency
it's
of course easier say than than done
and some among us
need a little bit more help
to not succumb for it when others do
and i've seen it it might be harder for
you if you're somewhere in uh you know
um
in a city
um you know in a city black america
maybe the environment might be a little
bit tougher um for you to try and get
your act together and all of that stuff
and it's okay
but
even in that situation
we need to um
i think it's important that we still do
not rob you of your agency
and this is where i am
mad as heck
against those who supposedly
um care
and their idea of how to make sure
that i don't become or stay a victim of
racism is through all the things we
talked about the crt the anti-racism
crap of um you know uh
abram x candy and
what's her name robin d'angelo i mean
her i'm shocked
the woman is making all of his money
supposedly fighting
a war on our behalf i'm like lady i hear
you lie loud and clear that you are true
racist i know but you told me you are
and for you to think that you're into
racism makes you less racist
and it's
that happens too she's she she comes
from a racist background fine she's
saying it it's true but this idea that
every walking person on earth
belongs to one category of the other
depending on what you know which skin
color you came with
it's it's problematic at its root so my
point is
does racism exist yes
do you think it's gonna stop me from
doing anything i have to do
no
might it make it harder longer
prob maybe
but it will not stop me
but for it not to stop me i can't engage
in victimhood mentality i can't lose my
self-esteem i i got i got to use all the
agency that i have
to fight back
and fight beyond see it's just soon just
better fight back you fight back and you
fight beyond because at some point
yeah and
it's this concept of yes and
so um this is why i have loved the job
so when i have somebody who is like oh
anti-racism is the way uh we're gonna go
and tell all the black all the white
kids that you know because they happen
to be white that they're really the
oppressors and blah blah blah and
they're black kids because they're black
you know
you're not changing anything when you're
doing that
nothing except that you're causing
you're putting problems where there were
no problems to start with all we had to
do was maybe
go for a different rat from there kids
are kids kids are born kids and this i'm
not sure if you want to get me going on
to the whole science of bias because
that's something i spent years of my
life on and my journey on the science of
bias
started with um
the days of philando castile eric garner
that whole summer of 2016
when we had this horrendous horrendous
uh situation of black people um being
killed by the police where they shot
before asking and the people left to die
in the most inhumane way for the rest of
us to watch from the social media
that's
me that's when my george afraid moment
happened not later four years ago in the
whole world he's like you know
um so
that
sent me on a journey of uh understanding
what discrimination is and bias is
um
and in a way that's the reason why i
started this company that i even called
skinny skin
that's where it came from again
criticized by creating
i
i needed to understand what
discrimination was how does it work is
it true what candy is saying is it true
what d'angelo is saying is it true that
but i it could it could be that your bad
your race is just because of a skin
color you happen to be born in is it
true
is it true i i needed to know
because i was at a time of my life where
at some point you know when when those
killings were happening it was so hard
for me um being a black person in this
country
and wondering
i mean what is this and
and what do we do with this
um yeah is it true how much
discrimination am i operating under in
the system
all of that and you need to understand
the full characteristics of if you're if
you're dreaming of making a big change
by building companies
you have to kind of
intuit how much what am i up against
what am i up against right and so this
is why you know spend all of his time on
some of the work and then eventually i
understood that um discrimination if you
wanted to understand it beyond
um it's um you know beyond the the big
lines of uh especially the the clickbait
lines would make it very black and white
then i had to really take a moment and i
spent time you know with a world of um
brain scientists with uh behavioral
psychologists
with evolutionary biologists to have all
of this ecosystem but together form what
we might one might call the science of
bias
and especially
i came across the work of this team of
scientists at the university of uh i
think it's wisconsin
and they're only ones who made sense
in this sea of nonsense back then
and this article wasn't political
and it was saying something that i could
relate with
and eventually
what i learned was
and this part comes from the
evolutionary biologist people
they in a way tell you that right around
age three
can happen sooner or later because you
know we're all different
but um you go from this person who has
to rely on these other people usually
your parents to stay alive
to be fed to be housed to be your diaper
change all of that stuff right to now
something is kicking in
where
you have
to in order for you to survive
and this is all wired in so you don't
even understand it consciously as i'm
saying it now
where in order for you to survive for in
order for you to go from this state of
dependency to another to the next step
to the next stage and more and more and
more
you're going to have to develop this
ability to make sense of the world and
what's making sense of a world at this
most basic level means is
can you determine if a situation or a
person is good or bad for you
failure and you need to be able to do so
do so ever so quickly
because failure to do to be able to do
that might means that you might not be
alive for next second
see it's so wired in
so this process starting to kick in
and at that point your brain is going to
be your best ally for that
and what the brain is going to do is
it's going to help you and the way the
brain works is through um it it works
with um for if it's all wired for
efficiency
and the way it um
it goes for efficiency is through
automation meaning that every time it
has computed and you probably know these
things way better than me every time it
has computed one algorithm
it doesn't right it doesn't want to do
it again it's almost like this okay got
it stored
stored right and then it adds maybe some
little levels of complexity to it but it
has to be something new meaning the new
level of complexity for it to even be
willing to reconsider
otherwise you have so then all of a
sudden what you have is
these neurons in the back of your head
and they have created pathways right so
and every time um neurons have created
pathway among themselves
because basically they're attached and
here's the pathway while this pathway in
the world of um
the in the world of um
science of bias
it's a habit in general it's a habit
when they form two pathways when they
form a pathway it's a habit so
if we're willing to talk about
unconscious bias because of course
it's very different from somebody who
tells me to my face
there's no world in which
you or i could ever be equal
because you're black and white you're a
woman i'm a man this peace and that
that people like that again 100 one
percent of psychopaths in our world
they're out there unfortunately by the
time we do nasty things it's pretty
horrible and that's what all we hear
about
but i'm talking mostly about the rest of
us remember when i told you that most of
us are good people bumbling along making
it up as we're going that's why i have
compassion for human nature
so
but really
in the morning when i wake up do you
really think that i'm waking up and
thinking how am i going to go kill how
am i going to go kill lex that next guy
needs to go down he's a man he's a don't
take me where i'm sure about some women
who feel like that but i'm not one of
them and i do think a majority of us are
not whatever
but you know in the morning i'm waking
up i'm just like
gee
can i get my tea
oh my dog is not looking okay today you
know we've got
right
it's a lot going on and so you're using
these kind of
just like you said brilliantly the brain
has a bunch of simplifications it's
built up yeah and he uses those
simplifications to get through the day
for the day exactly so so then here you
are needing to make sense of a world
and then the brain is your best ally in
that the way it's going to do it is for
efficiency efficiency done through
automation so every time it thinks it's
figured something out it's never going
to think about it again so that's how
you build all of these habits of
unconscious bias because everything so
it's somewhere along the line you come
up with um the with the information that
black men walking around with a hoodie
equals danger so later what do you see
whether it's lex oh my god i'm walking
in the dark alley i see a black man with
a hoodie maybe i'm gonna run away
because i've been
given that information so the best way
to think about it is the brain is a
hardware
and
and the software it runs on
is um what do you call it is a cultural
imprint
all of this information that we're
getting from the disney movies that
you're reading telling you that
themselves are to be saved by the prince
and all that stuff and girls wear pink
and or whatever
um you know you watch the movies and all
the movies whenever you watch about
africa they're talking about the blood
diamonds so we're talking to you about
slavery or we're talking about this and
then north wonder you walk away thinking
that all the ills of africa are caused
because of uh resource extraction the
diamonds or they're always fighting each
other look at uh i mean on the movie you
know or you know uh slavery all the time
you walk away and this is it
and we're all programmed along the same
line see that's the beauty of it
all of us are because even some black
people who are going to claim but they
didn't business when they registered
really so the truth so then when i
learned all of this i'm like wow this
concept of if you've got the brain
you've got biases
it comes with a territory that makes
sense
now
it doesn't mean we can't we can't
transcend that function of a brain and
that we should transcend it
right but i think it's very important
because once you understand that
a little bit more peace is created among
us because this is not about a black and
white or a yellow and green issue it's
about we are human issue
and these are part of things we
developed to you know to to to to keep
to to stay around
um just like we no longer have to rely
on um
you know this fear of flight um you know
like um ability of a brain because bears
over there start running and running
fast right today wherever bears show me
where they are but we have kept this
tendency
to go for fear uh fear of flight i don't
know how they say it and so we have this
you know courtesan done by the stress
you know stress triggers but back in the
days we have a stress trigger we run and
it's all you know expelled out but today
we get triggers and we don't know what
to do with it because where would we run
to what do we do
bears not even here so same thing here
with that and so when you realize this
whole thing that is now we what you
understand is that this problem is not
about anti-racism bs but it is about can
each one of us
do the work with a work is needed which
is we look inside
can we go for this work of
deprogrammation
this concept of a mindful practice
of undoing the habit of bias
and that doesn't
necessarily have to do with the simple
categorization of black and white
it's all kinds of biases everything it's
about everything and you know when i
started on that journey
and um me and my friend back then built
you know this practice of undoing your
habit of unconscious bias
we had all types of people come
and say wow i discovered that my bias is
against
larger people
and i'm like what what do you mean well
um i think i it seems to me like i felt
that larger people maybe are
are dumb
no we heard things and you know and you
don't judge
yeah you don't judge
and so and you see it's at every level
you know like um i don't know like
there's even this one friend she was
like you know when i looked into the
whole dating thing i absolutely didn't
want to have um you know asian men
because
she went her mind was into some
stereotypes about the size of whatever
and she was like no
but you see you once you start because
there's this whole thing of it's the
five step thing
bias awareness this uh underst basically
at this level what you're doing is
you're learning to spot the biases in
our culture because that's where the
cultural imprint comes from you're
watching this movie and you're realizing
just like i said well gee i realized
once again the black person is portrayed
like uh like the [ __ ] of a movie um
or you know um the latina lady this is
how she's been portrayed and you see it
everywhere even the npr npr is happening
like you're listening to something like
npr you to be more liberal than that
and this gentleman is asking these two
candidates one of them is a woman
political candidate if everyone is a man
i'm hearing as i'm asking the lady a
question that i know he's not going to
ask the man he didn't ask her he said
how do you um how do you balance uh
uh you know your race with a family
yeah does a man not have a family
right there you see it's very
subtle yeah but you see but because now
my mind is kind of trained to see things
i'm like interesting
or like when the media just says
froze
um
climate change issue on something
without even the choice of words so it's
pretty much everywhere you open the book
everywhere the interesting thing though
uh i mean even that man uh woman example
is i think it's really
um powerful to bring that bias to the
surface
but not let that lead to kind of fear
and paralysis that's right you should
almost i mean that's what humor is make
fun of it bring it to the surface
like acknowledge the fact that those
things are a part of the conversation
and a lot of them are
it is
you know
it's a cultural imprint because it's
part of culture and that might be there
could be you know i grew up in the
soviet union where the gender roles were
stronger than in other places that's
right and that's part of the culture we
have to acknowledge exactly that that
this is how this is affecting how i
think you might exactly we might like
how that works when we might not but we
have to acknowledge it and not get you
know make it part of humor make fun of
yourself you know all that kind of stuff
that that's the thing and so lex that's
why this first step is bias um bias
awareness so you get you train yourself
oh yeah okay that was one or it's where
you know and it's about it's in you it's
we're talking about you we're not and
then from there you like um
um replace the bias
like bias replacement
then it is um
where you practice the empathy you're
like gee wow i wonder how i would feel
every day i walk into a store and the
guy thinks he should be following me
because maybe i can i might steal
something because i'm black right
because when once you try that to put
yourself into a person's shoes all of a
sudden something else starts to click
and then from there you go on to
making connection
when you're making a connection and then
things start to change because now
you um no you're making um then you make
cultural immersion so this is where we
had some people like this one woman she
was very um uh quite uh very feminist
oriented
and um she had an issue with women
wearing their hijab and because for her
it was like how come you how come how
come you you you just slow you know like
how come you're accepting this demeaning
of yourself not understanding everything
else that comes with it
but through as she understood that she
even had that bias
then she went on through all the
different processes and then eventually
when comes the next step cultural
immersion she started going uh to the
most during ramadan when the muslims are
doing you know their uh it's the holy
month of um you know fasting and then we
break uh at night
and she started understanding very
different things and eventually happens
the last step that happens naturally
making a true real genuine connection
and this is where friendships happen
this is where that's it dubais can go
home now because it has been challenged
with reality
and understanding and so for me that is
what i was after
and then
but then the world was just like we
don't want to be told we're part of a
problem
so but i still reckon that it is the
type of mindfulness type of practice
that's going to happen and it's one
that's very internal
to to to you it is it is not and it
happens everybody at their own pace
so all of this i take it back
to um to racism the question you were
asking me
does racism exist yes it does is it
going to stop me from doing anything i
want to do no it's gonna make it harder
but
this is where for anybody who is serious
about
making sure
uh about fighting racism
i think the only job you have to do
is to
make sure
that people
keep their sense of self-agency
and b
can you help provide people with the
tools
to stand up so this is why i have so
much respect for van jones
uh people like van jones over at this
agreement on so many things but people
like um
miss alice uh johnson she was pardoned
uh by president trump through the work
of people like van jones and
kim kardashian and others they all
joined forces this is a case where
people of and and those folks then went
on to combine forces
furthermore
no no no regard given to their political
belongings they said if the issue is
criminal um criminal justice reform
then anybody who stands for it has to
come together and so
what they did in the situation with um
uh with um what they're doing criminal
justice reform in my mind
is a valid
uh action to fight
um racism in my mind because what are
you doing there you're trying to get
people out of jail who really have no
business being there
and also when you have people like
bishop omar
and the people he passed away
unfortunately but today we have anton
luck and lucky who was in jail for
having killed his um cousin you know he
um
had started i think he started the the
the gang in south uh dallas so we're
talking really tough guy who was reading
the wrong side of uh of the equation and
then in in jail literally he found plato
the cave and all that so today these
people
i'm like why don't we hear more about
them the urban specialists
because these people it's not about the
anti-racism crap of candy or diane jones
said again until the cows come home but
it is about we go where help is needed
we go in herb we go in um in urban you
know um inner city inner city uh black
inner city neighborhoods and block by
block we change the culture
and they say it like that it's their
words these are african-american people
who have as many rights as anybody else
to talk about their own culture and they
will tell you
we have to change the culture i have
some some videos like that on my youtube
with um bishop omar what these people
are doing is what we need to do bishop
will explain in size sometimes people
are
they're their feets and feet deep down
in the mud
and what we have to do is to try to pull
them up
and you cannot say you didn't pull them
up because we're not seeing the head out
yet but how much how much progress have
they made from the bottom
to where they are now
and keep
going so what i see these people doing
you see i have so much i i love and
respect glenn larry and company you know
and ian rove and all those guys i i love
them i i love a lot of things that they
say
um
you know this whole concept of personal
response we don't know that
but i'm just like at some point it also
needs to be matched up
with real actions yeah and that's what
the people like anton lucky urban
specialists um alice johnson are doing
they're going where it's hard alex
johnson is getting people out of jail
every single day literally and then
people like anton lucky and his team are
giving them the tools to live the gang
life
to to be better people to go for a life
of redemption
this is happening right now but what i
find is they're not getting the bulk of
your attention yeah but this is anybody
who's serious about this is why how i
would love to see people do anti-racism
is help lift people up for real action
support support um a school choice
support school choice black mamas are
they know what's going on and when they
tell you we want school choice they know
what to talk about they're not idiots
yeah
especially at the local level yes
helping them at the local level yes so
help them
make sure that they can take their kids
out of these public schools that are
doing horrendous things to them you know
miss virginia watch that movie how could
you not
support black moms in this country to
take the kids to safety when it comes to
education how come not that's what i
want to see happen and not like some
yeah let's go to some
classrooms and everybody's white you go
over here everybody's the next state you
go over here and kids let us tell you
about this no no no no
as a black person i don't want you to do
any of that crap
let me grow my wings
yeah if you want help put some fuel
behind them and let me take my flight
that's all i'm asking for but the only
way for you to do
um a for that's the only way for you to
be part of a racism battle if that's
what you think is the most important
battle of our life
that's it that's what i have to say
about that and so for me i'm keeping my
head very straight it's about what
uh enables
black people
to thrive
i don't need for you to be an activist
on my behalf
no because when you're doing that you're
doing exactly what you've been doing to
us black people in africa our whole life
i don't need your white savior complex
because that's what anti-racism is white
savior complex that stuff doesn't work
it only works to make you feel better
about how superior you are to me but it
does nothing absolutely nothing to
change my everyday life if it is not if
it is at least in the african side
to actually even change my um
you know turn me into somebody who's
waiting for handouts
so
if peop i would encourage people to
really those people who are really
serious about wanting to be part of a
solution and i know there are many out
there for the love of god and everything
that's out there and we care about
stop
it it's it's about think about what's
gonna
um
um enable people maybe the word is
wrongly chosen but you know what i'm
talking about yeah give them
to spread their wings yes give a person
um yeah learn to teach a person how to
fish and don't give them a fish when you
put in your stupid signs on a lawn uh
with black lives matter and all that
crap you're not helping and when you're
buying one more anti-racism book or or
as a company you know financing one more
dei you know um if it done along those
lines i think we've got a problem yeah
so you do think that the um the efforts
of uh diversity equity and inclusion are
often not effective not only are we not
effective but they also backfire and
there are reports on all of us
and at the end of the day it makes sense
it makes sense
so for me i am very very glad that
people um have developed an
enlightenment about this
very happy about that very
but let us not keep going for the easy
perceived solution to problems
again they've done this to us the poor
people of africa
they thought the solution was to give
it does not work
and then they say oh we're going to do a
social uh social um social
entrepreneurship on you tom's shoes buy
one pair of shoes and we give one pair
of shoes to some people in poor
countries
then guess what happened to us
you know in the town where we operate in
senegal where i have my little
manufacturing
two
we have 2 000 little mom and pop
businesses and guess what they happen to
be in lex
shoemakers
right
so you have issue makers each one of
them hires at least 5-15 people do the
math
family businesses
guess what happens to them the day the
tongue shoes truck shows up with bunch
of free shoes
yeah who can who can compete against
free now all of these people little by
little are going to have to close their
shops because who can compete against
free because tom shoes dumping all of
his shoes on them
and then they go out of business and now
instead of helping anybody you actually
sent all the kids who depended on these
adults working in these places now they
have to join the rank of kids who need
to be given shoes because you took their
parents ability
to make money
through their wages
buy them shoes
you see so first they said we just have
to give so that was um a primarily um
you know the charity business
and
um you still have foreign aid business
going on so we just need to give
and then the social entrepreneurs came
in place but i'm like the only person
for this business is good is for blake
mccarthy you know the founder of tom
shoes but other than that i'm not sure
really seeing who else is winning from
this
and then they and and so today my whole
thing is
we got a challenge
to have a mind for the poor
or to have a mind for the lesser
fortunate maybe in this country
it is easy
and lesser fortunate because you know
for anybody that you see you you feel
like is being trampled upon because of
something maybe it's because of economic
circumstances or maybe it's race in this
case or whatever
to have a heart
for the lesser fortunate among us for
whatever reason
that's easy
but to have a mind for them that's a
challenge
you